hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to voidtrain this video is
sponsored by epic games and this game
uh is a strange one it's where you build
a train
in a void and then you fight on that
train against other people on trains i'm
just giving you a description of the
trailer that i saw this isn't
necessarily what the game is about but i
saw it and it looked great so i'm gonna
play it character ooh old as hell
pale is the summer mourn browse like a
god body
thickhams that's good
medium thick ems okay
so what this game is about i'm not
necessarily sure i don't know the story
there was an intro sequence i kind of
skipped it over because i am impatient
about those kind of things okay kinders
it is time to come out one by one yeah
yeah yeah everything will be circled we
have got tea pretzels and more fantastic
beer
come on in collagen
what
yours they don't seem to want to come
out
scheisse they're gonna have to do it the
hard way
bring insecures
um okay
hold on a second
i mean you can pluck the goose if you
want
i'm not i'm central why you pluck the
goose but
okay whatever it tells me to lock the
door so i'm gonna lock the door this is
it
we now begin plugging off
yeah okay
okay so apparently i have powers to draw
on everything that i want which is
exactly what i was thinking that this
game was about
oh
okay so we got some kind of german
experiments going on here which uh
in my history and everyone's history
isn't always good but could be okay
all right so what do i do pick up whoa
[Music]
maybe we should give up
jonas good good it's a door harder okay
whatever anyway so it's time to get to
training
[Music]
all right what is this what am i doing
turn
all right sure yeah okay
go to the other world let me try
i kind of love the obscure world
building where you don't really
idiot
where there's like no explanation of
what's going on and you're just kind of
thrown into a universe so you don't
understand i do like that i like being
confused
sometimes because it's not so much about
being confused it's about being
uncertain of what's happening right so
the world around you is new
i hate it i hate it
yeah is that supposed to be cute
oh i hate it i hate it
i hate this little suction mouth
oh no they are multiplying
that's awful i hate that world's cool
though
if i had to quantify it i'm guessing
that this game is kind of base building
but i don't really know the base is the
train right so
i wanna take the trolley off the brake
okay follow you i don't think i should
be going the journey into the into the
in between begins
our heroes are about to start their
adventure
wait wait wait forward not backwards
oh goodness just use this transmission
thingy
okay shift the transmission
all right good good good good okay all
right okay
sure sure sure
uh
here
transmission handle yes
good good
okay now our heroes are definitely about
to begin their adventure through the
many dangers that lie ahead
oh so much excitement awaits
that's pretty cool okay no this is not
good at this rate we'll never finish
this story i don't want to be that guy
but
maybe we should hurry a little bit
maybe we should
what is this shiny organ organics
[Music]
all right yes
i expected no less from you full ahead
alonse
okay whatever scrap metal is this scrap
metal oh boy
is it gonna pull me along if i'm going
pretty quick how do i slow down
you didn't exactly tell me how to slow
this thing down oop i see you
hey watch my nog
hello
chemical that's good and obscure oh yes
yes yes dirty
ice okay well this is surreal and
awesome
i love deep landscapes like that i love
just things that go on forever
they're very aesthetically pleasing now
i [ __ ] blanked myself
it feels almost raft-esque in terms of
like the
i've got my little am i gonna oh
can i hold f back to the train yoink
yep oh there's wood wood wood is that
what that's wood right
yeah
that might be metal
wow
i know that's supposed to be cute but i
really don't find it cute at all
can i please get that i'm not gonna get
that in time no
that's okay um
oh it's beautiful
it's goddamn gorgeous it is very
raft-esque it's extremely raft but not
quite you know what i mean i i i
hesitate to say that it's immediately
like oh this is just raft because it's
not it's clearly not it's like you go
out you get scraps you get metal you get
organics you get all the goodies
and then you see these islands popping
up all around you
oh that would look like something like a
rock
there we go no that's metal
hey can i get some wood oh ooh
aha
okay here we go
build book here we go
build book that's what i was looking for
t to open up the build book can i t to
open
i get it t to open up the build there we
go
a reese it is oh it is oh it is oh it is
you know what put that right
oh it is
i love this i can already tell i love
this all right research the technology
of the smelter you got it baby
research the technology of the smelter i
need two more metal to be able to do
that okay i can do that i love this game
i can already tell i'm gonna love this
game
oh so instead of throwing a hook out to
get anything i just throw myself which
you know honestly
is much better but i have a funny
feeling that throwing myself out in the
future is going to be very risky and not
going to be entirely pleasant imagine if
it was just a giant void shark swimming
through the
whatever you call this cause there's
those cute things which you know if
there's cute adorable things there's
probably going to be big scary things
that eat the cute adorable things that's
kind of how it goes
unless i'm the person that eats the cute
adorable things which frankly i don't
want to
horrible space diseases it's gonna give
me
okay that should be four so i should be
able to bam all right researching that
oh it doesn't take long at all
so then i just gotta build the smelter
and i have a funny feeling it's gonna
cost even more metal i bet that
eventually i'm gonna be able to pull in
these giant pieces of metal
and then i'm gonna be able to break them
down because it all seems like it's just
goodies you know what i mean this is
cool
this is dope as hell what is that
what is that
do i want to know what that is
okay i loved unannounced horrible things
that looked like they could kill me in
an instant i love that
i love that i love it
okay i guess it's fading away
maybe do i eventually get nets that are
gonna help me gather this stuff
oh there we go metal metal metal
okay that's was that enough i don't know
idea ah damn three god dammit
metal there we go
so cool this is so cool all right
so we got that let's get my smelty
why
oh okay
let's put you right
here
okay
and exit
okay
what can i create in here
iron bar more metal god metal is just
necessary all right
understood
understood i just need a constant stream
of metal
i get it i understand
this is so cool
it scratches the exact same itch that
raft does and raft is just a very
appealing one i wonder if they'll put
co-op in this i wonder if there is co-op
in this i didn't even think about it i
didn't even look into it
how's that thing behind me oh it's gone
okay well that's even more worrisome
because then it isn't just a thing
that's in the environment that was
actually a thing
that's more worrisome but whatever
all right let's make two iron bars go
for it no oh fuel oh interesting uh wood
let's put five in
bam
iron bar two go for it
create
cool so that while that's working i'll
go grab what i can more oh i'm not gonna
make that ah nice too late
that
this just look at the landscaping
[Music]
yeah i'm not gonna worry about that
perfectly normal when you jump into the
ethereal void of eternity which i
currently find myself in staring into
the horizon of a black hole
give give giving
never enough metal
[Music]
and pick up okay what do i do with it
that's the limit of my tutorial okay
that's all i get the rest is up to me i
see that and i appreciate it
hell yeah i'm on my own
in the middle of a horrible nothingness
a beautiful nothingness but you know a
beautiful and horrible kind of go hand
in hand sometimes when it comes to voids
in space and stuff like that which it
kind of feels like i'm in or at least in
a space between dimensions or whatever
either way i love it
i do love it
this is fantastic
okay so ooh horn yeah
[Music]
i love that okay well let's just go for
uh wait why does this say hold t
hammer
hammer
oh
oh multi-tool mode
oh i could repair things okay what i
probably gotta do is i probably have to
research
container
uh at least let me get the container
researched
now while that's going
more metal metal metal oh come on no no
no no no
if you have ah damn it i wonder if i'll
be able to research like flippers or
something to be able to swim faster
through the through the whatever this is
oh give give no no no
there we go okay so i can't jump
directly off of the platform to be able
to go straight up
me like rocket boots or something
oh what am i looking at
what
well that's different what
what am i looking at why is the music
getting all big why is the music what
chains
what is happening um
uh
wow
i love the scope of this this
is just huge
it's so cool see this is what i mean by
throwing you into the deep end of
something without any understanding you
get moments like this where you're just
like this is
freaking nuts what is that
it's huge
[Applause]
what the hell
i love it i love it i love it
i love this
i love it so much
hunk
i love it oh
okay
i did it
what did i do
i'm sorry
uh oh
i surround for some time now our heroes
are trying to understand where they are
and who could possibly build such
wonders yep exactly upon further
inspecting the platform it becomes
obvious to them that someone used to
live here oh an idea occurs to our brave
adventurers investigating the abandoned
depot
okay i will investigate the abandoned
depot i am investigating
uh hello
who used to live here ah
the germans
okay
oh
and of course suddenly it's horror game
oh yeah
oh yeah oh this is
oh hi
hello nice gun i'll take that i have a
pistol now
somebody has been in good graces with
the goddess of luck
a weak secondary weapon with infinite
ammo it is enough to deal with the
initial enemies enemies the revolver can
be upgraded with modules picked up on
the enemy through the armory when you
research and build it
enemies
what is that beautiful bang
wow oh infinite ammo
all right my dude thank you to you and
the goddess of luck
wow look at that that's uh
i shot it
all right anything else down here that's
going to be jumping out of me now that i
have a gun all right cool um
let's go then leave the depot
this is so
freaking cool
this is so freaking cool i i i had no
idea this is what this game was gonna be
like because just seeing like the
trailer i was like oh it seems pretty
cool seems like there's some crafting
seems like there's some like cool
visuals
and i guess i'm back into it wow that is
so fun
that is so fun
oh i love that i don't know why i need a
beast
but i think you're gonna tell me bang
boom
all right sure maybe i shouldn't shoot
at the
thing that seems like it could
extinguish my life in a moment with a
wave of its pinky toe i'm in love
i'm in love i am in love with this game
god i hope i'm still recording i am in
love with this game am i am i still
recording good good i am so i just need
a lot more metal and i don't think i can
shoot any leeches leeches won't do any
damage but they will slow the train
shoot these creatures in time because
the more they get stuck on the wagons
the greater the speed penalty okay
great
yeah gross are there any leeches there
right now
i don't see any leeches
are those those things that
were at the beginning
i knew they were bad
nope
that's right kabbalam get out of here
someone on space
i have an inventory
what
oh i did research a container okay
uh wooden metal god it just needs so
much metal
it's an endless stream of metal
[Music]
change
[Music]
endless stream of metal ah come here
[Music]
metal metal metal metal
where's the metal come on
metal
metal metal metal metal metal metal
metal metal
okay if it's not metal i'm not going to
pick it up i have a bad habit of
whenever i start out these games i just
pick up
get back get back
i have a bad habit of picking up
absolutely everything even though i
don't necessarily need to do medal
yes
metal
medal
medal
i apologize to anybody that thought that
those things were cute but i know that
they're going to be a menace in the
future just like spider-man not a hero
an absolute plague upon our society that
we're trying to build here
don't be fooled by their cuteness
no no no metal metal ah god damn it
where's my inventory what's in my is
that all i'm full of dirty ice i'm full
of pea ice and nothing else ah leech
bleach
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang
what what is that i want it what is it
what is it no inventory inventory
inventory no inventory give me sorry if
you die if you die drop the dirty poop
ice god damn it oh no no
hello hi
all right so i'm not doing too great or
i'm doing amazingly i can't tell which
but either way i have metal and too much
poop ice
let's go ahead and oh god
am i stuck i i need to build a storage
but i don't have enough oh i do have
enough okay i'm good i'm good i'm good
okay
so i'm gonna put storage right here oh
yeah that'll fit bam okay
now they have that let's put all my poop
ice in there
[Music]
don't know why i have so much
and then my organics five percent food
oh i do have a hunger bar interesting
all right so grab that put the metal in
many as i can blam it up i need more
fuel oh i need more fuel
i'm gonna need a more efficient way to
do any of this metal metal metal wood
wood metal wood metal metal wood wooden
ah that's fine
here we go
wood
just gonna go for wooden metal now i'm
not gonna worry about anything else
because i don't need anything else
wood and metal well done
[Applause]
what did i just oh god i thought that
was a thing trying to get ahead of
myself here
blam got it okay and
blam got it okay
okay
okay okay okay
okay what can i research
uh basic components okay that's good
that'll help me build more advanced
stuff maybe eventually i could get a
an extension to my train i'm going to
start running out of space soon enough
who's there
oh it's you [ __ ] no it's something
else
what is there ah no that's metal i need
that what is doing that what is it
what
i don't like that you're making me miss
metal okay okay all right
so i researched that what do i need the
copper components i need three coppers
okay
bam
let's see what do we have in here i
probably need to build another crate but
i don't know if i just want to dumb
metal into that
nah
okay metal metal metal metal wood
now this game just scratches an itch
that very few games
can properly scratch you know what i
mean
it's like the crafting the scavenging
the building you know all of it in one
and just a little bit of combat but
maybe it'll be a lot more combat in a
little bit i have no idea but just like
the idea of building up that's something
that raft didn't have it didn't have
like
i mean there were enemies and there was
a shark but it never felt like it was a
core piece of the game and so i would
love the uh oh
no i would love this idea that you know
you have to build up your base to
survive i always love like tower defense
style things and that's not what i'm i
don't think that's what this is gonna be
but it's like you build your base
because it's also important to protect
your base you know what i mean i like
the building i like scavenging building
and protecting like it's it's like three
different cycles that all matter you
know the risk you know the risk of
losing everything that you built
once you get to a certain point at raft
it like it's negligible oh if the shark
bites it you know you could just lose a
little bit you know subnautica ah you
know you might die but you can always
come back you know but like the idea
that you could lose everything that you
built
i'm wondering if this game kind of has
that alright so what do i have and what
could i build
storage is production
well not a whole lot workbench right the
workbench
okay i need one more medal no it's too
early wait no hang on i need more metal
i need more metal metal metal metal wait
no it's too soon i'm not ready to go
i don't want to face another challenge
please i'm not ready no no no don't
start the music no where's the metal
damn you damn you metal pedal
a metal metal
metal
metal okay that's uh i just need one
more of these hang on hold on
hold on
okay so i'm gonna build this
get my workbench oh it's teensy i can
put it then right
rotate rotate got it
bam okay
okay and then i can create from here
probably more metal let me guess
metal
oh my god the metal
okay here we go then the temple of
caboose
yes yes very impressive i'm i am
starving am i am i starving oh my god
i'm starving starving
how do i make food
uh
use
use use dirty ice
use use pure ice okay so there's dirty
ice and then there's pure ice
damn that's dope all right let's just go
for it let's go for it come on
if we're going to go for it we're going
to go for it
speed up
honka lanka
i wish i could hold it down
wow
that is cool
ah scale scope it's so fun
it's so fun
it's like destiny you know one of the
great things about destiny is the world
seems so big in the background like they
get that illusion really well
just very well done here i do like it a
lot
nice nice nice all right what other
secret base are you going to put me in
no
hello ah
great
narrator are you going to speak to us
don't feed whatever that is okay
no i think i'm on my own now
okay
oh yeah i'll go down
oh yeah you know i will oh i can melee i
don't like the idea that i need to melee
anything
okay
whack
whap
wham
a metal i like that okay
wham
is this just like a random pit stop does
that not actually mean anything
um
i don't i i don't like that
oh i don't like it
is there nothing else here
wow
that's a whole lot of nothing
okay
can i park or up here
no
well oh another container over here
wood
great
what in the hell are you
what no
no
no
okay
all right just a normal pit stop
nothing weird
i want to go home i want to go home
i would like to go now
lock down parking
locked down parking
leave the okay i'm leaving
because i don't want anything to do with
that
i don't know what the next world is
gonna be
deep in the void oh boy
a terrible carnivore creature is drawing
closer to its prey no
our heroes should be more vigilant in
the future
what
don't just say that
don't say things like that okay so i'm
out of time for this one here but this
is void train void training is very cool
if you want to try this for yourself the
link is in the description uh you can
find it on the epic game store and if
you do get it use my creative code mark
buy it but also just like holy hell this
is amazing if you want to see me play
more of this because i kind of want to
play more of this just to see where it's
going to go i don't know what this
predator that they're talking about but
i have a funny feeling it's going to be
some kind of a void shark
but either way let me know what you
thought down in the comments thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you